jeter 100 sur ton ventre le tremblement
qu'angers pire est puissante que tu
comprends catherine major on vous a vu
deux semaines en facebook live piano
voix pour le centre national des arts et
vous vous apprêtez à récidivé vendredi
prochain avec un lancement virtuel de
votre cinquième album comment ça va se
passer
ça va être une première on s'est dit en
fait je me suis dit que tant captant caf
pas faire de lancement avec les gens et
je trouvais que c'était dommage de pour
souligner la sortie fake je vais faire
quelque chose chez moi qui me suis moins
passa pas à pas de loup et quant au fond
des bois
je vais interpréter des chansons au
piano parce qu'évidemment je peux pas
voir minutie même si mon album est très
loin de du piano cette fois ci mais je
vais en interpréter quelques-unes comme
ça puis j'ai bu c'est d'offrir peut-être
une capsule de commandes commencent
effet l'enregistrement avec leur caisse
depuis tous les yeux je vais essayer en
fait d'offrir une heure de d'un mix de
d'être toutes sortes de petites choses
qui sont réalisables avec nos moyens
il ya beaucoup d'artistes qui
présentement offrent leur contenu
gratuitement sur le web vous vous allez
faire un lancement virtuel vous faudra
payer 10 $ pour avoir l'album et
assister au lancement du disque je
croyais pas un piège aussi a trop donné
son contenu mais je crois qu'il ya un
piège à donner le contenu mois dans wii
parce que parce que c'est pas la réalité
d'abord mois le lancement que je fais
d'abord il va coûter de l'argent parce
que je doit engager des gens dans mon
cas le 10 $ qui est chargé c'est pas
compliqué en fait ces dix dollars que
les gens payent pour acheter l'album
en fait c'est seul concept on a tendance
à jamais avoir envie de charge et quand
on est artiste parce qu'on faisait à ce
que le sable est ce que ça vaut ça
est-ce que
c'est comme je dis tonton on a besoin de
partager donc et on se disait on se fait
du bien aussi été mais en même temps la
réalité est que c'est moi par exemple et
tous les artistes on a des comptes à
payer comme tout le monde on a des
enfants à nourrir on ne on a une vie
donc il faut c'est un danger
effectivement pour ceux et celles qui
vous connaissent pas la maison va vous
êtes formé justement en musique
classique au jazz
votre nouvel album s'intitule carte mère
est la première chanson sur cet album
s'intitule le bateau c'est un hommage à
la maternité
c'est important pour vous par la
maternité sur cet album le visiblement
bay la maternité est au centre de ma vie
depuis dix ans donc j'ai quatre enfants
entre 0 et 10 ans ça m'a changé dès la
première je pense que tout le monde qui
a des enfants savent à quel point ça
change une vie
puis après je pense que c'est impossible
de faire de l'art de faire quoi que ce
soit qui ait porté par cet amour le
quotidien et 7 et le fait que ça prend
beaucoup d'énergie et beaucoup de temps
et beaucoup de préoccupations donc y est
c'est sûr que toute la création et est
un titre par vous parler que l'or est
teintée par la maternité mais autant de
la pandémie s'occuper de quatre jeunes
enfants ça doit vous laisser moins de
temps pour créer ça servait tout un
casse-tête
c'est un pas pire casse tête j'ai la
création je crois que c'est c'est quoi
une option en ce moment là pour
l'instant j'essaie de mettre en oeuvre
ce qu'il faut pour pour que les gens
reçoivent ce disque là ce qui est pas
évident parce que c'est tout des
nouvelles méthodes tout le monde on
s'ajuste pions on voit comment lancer ça
comment comment envoyer ça dans le
firmament
comme dirait mon ami à rien mais gégé
j'essaie en fait c'est on est parent à
temps plein le pire on est en train de
construire notre rénover notre potager
et puis planter nos légumes
éventuellement puis on essaie de faire
l'école à la maison moi j'allais t on
prendre fin dans l'ansé de faire tout en
même temps
j'avoue des fois on est à bout de
souffle
je c'est normal
[Musique]
en terminant catherine major vous ne
pouvez pas compter sur les redevances de
ventes d'albums pour gagner votre vie
vous comptez sur la scène toutes les
salles de spectacles sont fermées alors
quand et comment comptez vous retourner
sur scène j'avoue que moi j'ai beaucoup
de mal à comprendre ce qui se passe en
ce moment le retour à l'école je sais je
le comprends pas vraiment je comprends
je comprends pas donc j'ai de la misère
à évaluer pas donner mon opinion là
dessus honnêtement mais c'est sûr que
c'est sûr que je pense pas que ce soit
en 2020 selon moi c'est pas en 2000 mais
en tout cas j'espère un 2021 sinon on va
vraiment falloir qu déjà grandissent mon
pote agir encore plus quelques majors
merci beaucoup merci merci à toi mais je
sais que tu es là que tu ne partira pas
souhaité parler des